did you steal a hammer at least did you
take how many hammers do you have
uh about five working on a marvel movie
is exciting enough
but wouldn't you want to bring a
souvenir home to remember your time on
set
marvel blockbusters are decorated with
flashy props and costumes
so it'd be easy to see why some of the
celebrities behind the films would want
to take some of these items with them
after filming
even when they're not really supposed to
here are some of the props that these
marvel stars decided to take from the
set
i'm like oh i lost the tony stark
glasses and like you what
now they're on my mantelpiece tom
holland has taken home props from every
single project he's worked on
leading to his home being littered with
movie props so of course he jumped at
the chance to take home props from his
marvel films
while holland has tried numerous times
to take spider-man's iconic suit
he wasn't successful however he was able
to keep the webhead's trusty web
shooters as well as tony stark's glasses
that became an integral part of the plot
in spider-man far from home
that definitely makes you wonder if he's
ever tried out those web shooters
could you get in trouble for it i mean i
haven't so far
holland is also a bit weirded out by the
fact that the props department has a
foam manikin of him
while on the set of homecoming holland
was hoping to take home the mannequin so
he could proudly display his spider-man
costume he had his eyes on
it's a little bit difficult to walk out
of the set in a spider-man suit
robert downey jr has quite a bit in
common with the eccentric tony stark
so obviously the prop he would snatch
from the set wouldn't be your average
item
while filming the 2015 sequel avengers
age of ultron
the avengers giant a in the front of the
team's headquarters
caught the eye of downey i said uh why
is this in
in england send it back to la i'll put
it in my office they're like seriously
i said yeah yeah i'll wait and it's
there i have it
if you were playing captain america
wouldn't you want to bring home that
iconic shield
well chris evans definitely took
advantage of that and brought home
several parts of his captain america
costume they gave me the shield
they gave me the cowl i'm gonna ask for
the full suit i never asked for the full
suit hemsworth got the full suit
i want the full suit come on marvel it's
only fair
if thor gets to keep his suit then cap
definitely deserves to keep his
costumes a bit much so tight working
with a prop such as thor's trusty hammer
mjolnir would be quite tempting
at least chris hemsworth thinks so as he
has taken home around
five hammers one of the hammers is
proudly placed right next to the toilet
almost like a glorified toilet paper
holder often people stay in there a
little longer and i think it's because
of the hammer
since hemsworth is a father of three
that does mean that his hammers have
inevitably gotten a little banged up
it's pretty heavy him and and one of my
sons in particular whose beefy little
kid certainly is sort of
papa look look so the hammer's got a few
dents in it a few scratches
not only does hemsworth have five
versions of mjolnir
he also has thor's stormbreaker from
infinity war
and endgame that's quite the collection
tom hiddleston claims that his memento
from filming
isn't as impressive as some of his
co-stars souvenirs
while he would have loved to have taken
the god of mischief's trademark horns or
his staff
his souvenir is actually something that
comes from the very first thor film
the scarf his character wears upon
arriving on earth
loki is worthy too we all know that ryan
reynolds is in love with playing the
merc with a mouth and he even shares
deadpool's sense of snark
you may be wondering why the red suit
well that's so bad guys can't see me
bleed
reynolds couldn't pass up on the
opportunity to bring home deadpool's
iconic red suit
even though he knew he really wasn't
supposed to there's no space
in that thing at all after 10 years of
waiting to finally do his favorite
character justice on the last day of
filming the first film
reynolds drove off set while wearing
deadpool's signature style
definitely earned it i know right
tom holland even managed to take props
that most people would find
boring and repurpose them for other uses
once he brought them back to his house
he ended up taking a blue screen from
the set of far from home
and turned it into a cover for his poker
table hey who wouldn't want a reminder
that they're
spider-man while playing poker i am a
walking meme
since karen gillan looks completely
unrecognizable as nebula
she has a very different voice to me
you'd think she'd want to take something
home to prove to her friends that she's
really nebula gillen revealed that she
still has the metal arm that nebula
wears despite the frustrating experience
on set of having to get it fitted every
morning
it's a lovely experience first thing in
the morning the late chadwick boseman
truly loved being in the mcu as the king
of wakanda
and of course he didn't want to leave
the set of the film empty-handed
bozeman souvenir was a bit of a humbler
choice than some of his co-stars
i have the beats the kimono beat though
bozeman did consider taking home black
panther's hero
armor ultimately he decided he didn't
want to go through all that trouble
chris pratt won over fans with his
iconic portrayal of star-lord
but fans have also appreciated his
character's sense of style
pratt definitely thought so too as he
took home his character's costume
he did want to put it to good use by
wearing it to visit kids in children's
hospitals
if it was a big enough movie to work it
would mean something to a kid who's sick
in a hospital for
peter quill or star-lord to come visit
him i'll do that that would give me real
meaning
for this movie you know it was a pretty
big deal when two-time academy
award-winning actress kate blanchett
joined the mcu
as thor's villainous half-sister hella
it's
not possible darling you have no idea
what's possible
despite her high prestige as an actress
blanchett is clearly still
a big fan of the marvel cinematic
universe so much so that she actually
took home one of the prop mjolnirs
which she has in her home you have
mjolnir
i have munir sebastian stan's memento
is something that may not be as cool as
some of his fellow co-stars
but it certainly does hold some memories
i'm just gonna tell him i have an
endless supply of k-y jelly
both stan and karen gillen explained
that the lubricant was actually used to
help them put on their character's metal
arms
robert denny jr actually gave tom
holland's youngest brother patty one of
the most significant props in the entire
mcu
when the 2018 marvel film black panther
was being released
downey invited holland and his brother
to watch the film at his house
and even ended up giving paddy the
surprise of a lifetime
there was like a bang or something and
then i heard patty go oh my god
oh my god and i thought he'd like ripped
a picasso off the wall or something but
it turns out that robert had given him
his original ironman mask from the first
film
despite having only starred in two
movies as the famous webslinger
andrew garfield definitely seemed to
love playing the iconic role
i got to work with incredible actors a
really great director garfield wasn't
actually allowed to take home his suit
from the amazing spider-man 2
despite multiple copies of the suit
being around on set
regardless he ended up smuggling the
spidey suit off set
hoping nobody would notice that one of
the 25 suits
was missing i knew it was the right
thing for me to do
hugh jackman has played the feral clawed
mutant wolverine for over 20 years
and now it feels like nobody could ever
possibly replace him
jackman revealed that he kept a
wolverine costume from every
x-men movie he appeared in as well as
the anti-hero signature claws
he did admit that he sold many of the
costumes for charity
but hinted that he may have kept one or
two just to wear from time to time you
know on a saturday night
exactly like that michael rooker's yondu
was a definite scene stealer in both
guardians of the galaxy films
since rooker is such close friends with
director james gunn
he was able to take a few props home
with him rooker reveals that he was able
to take the orb from the first movie
home
as well as yondu's glass frog i like to
stick them all
in a roll on my control console most of
all
rooker was able to keep yondu's trusty
fin
you think when i make this arrow fly i
use my head
thor ragnarok director and star taika
waititi is known for quirky sense of
comedy in all of his projects
my name is cool made of rocks as you can
see but don't get that intimidating
instead of taking a prop from set he
actually brought one of his own personal
items to use on this set of the film
the shake weight that carl urban scourge
uses in one memorable scene of the film
waititi claims that the item did hold
some sentimental value to him
which makes it pretty obvious that he
brought the shake weight back with him
after the film was done
shooting to be honest oh i didn't know
what i was doing
it wasn't only just the actors who were
able to snag some mementos from the set
of their films
guardians of the galaxy director james
gunn revealed on instagram that he took
a souvenir from the set of the first
film the robotic leg that rocket raccoon
snatches during the prison scene in the
first film
now proudly sits in gun's front office
hopefully the leg's real
owner isn't missing it too much what did
he look like hopping around
i had to transfer him 30 000 units
anthony and joe russo have become two of
the biggest filmmakers in hollywood
after their work on both the last two
captain america films
as well as the last two avengers movies
anthony russo reveals that he took home
a collection of some of the most
important props in the entire
mcu the infinity stones well i already
i already have a set a lovely set of
infinity stones so that's
that's a pretty precious prop scott
derrickson was clearly passionate about
directing dr strange's trippy and
mind-bending origin tale
there was one specific prop that he had
his eyes on while helming the film
which he eventually took home with him
the eye of agamotto
derekson picked the prop because it was
small enough to fit in his home but at
the same time it was vital to the film
itself
that's mine i told it's the one prop i
took it's easy to see
why these marvel stars fancied the props
that they took home with them
from the little things like scarves or a
blue screen to something important like
captain america's mighty shield
or thor's hammer these stars knew
exactly what they wanted
is there a prop from a marvel movie that
you'd want to take home